We all begin as one version of ourself
but as we grow life changes us every moment
shaping our character shifting our priorities
stretching every fiber of our being until we
think we've lost ourselves to the stress of it all
but that's not true because under the torn
fibers is a stronger person forged like
steel with the courage to fight for those we
love and what we thought was lost can be found
in family.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is
going to be my new superman trailer video
they just released this new footage obviously they're
hyping up a bunch of multiverse stuff here
so i'll explain what's going on because it's actuallya big deep cut for infinite crisis
for those of you that read that comic book story line
becausehenry cavill has also been talking about coming
back as superman and it seems like he's going to
be cameoing in a couple big dc movies really soon
i'll also explain some of the news about man of
steel 2 and the future of superman in the movies
if you're new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos but obviously the big thing
here this new superman trailer is premiering at
the end of february alongside the flash so it'll
be the superman and flash on tuesdays for the cw
but it's all about the multiverse and introducing
the new version of his family that they sort of
rebooted a little bit with crisis on infinite
earths he says we all begin as one version
of ourselves that's a reference to all the
other superman actors like christopher reeve henry
cavill brandon ralph tom welling everyone there's
been many different versions of superman you see
the ken farm in the background they're using the
same kent farm from the smallville tv show so
obviously the series is sort of a successor to
smallville there'll be a lot of smallville energy
in this series and i wouldn't be surprised if a
bunch of smallville actors cameo on the show
either in their old roles or as new characters
yes of course tom welling could always cameo in
the future if he wants to i think that they would
have him anytime he wanted to come on but if you
remember christopher reeve former superman also
cameoed on smallville back in the day so
there's a long history of old superman actors
cameoing on the new superman tv shows why me there
must be a reason why i was sent to this planet
you won't find the answers by looking
to the stars it's a journey you'll have
to take by looking inside yourself
you must write your own destiny call
i know there's a lot of questions about what's
happening with brandon rouse version of superman
because his superman is canonically the same
version as the christopher reeve superman just
a little further forward in the timeline there's
also the chance of him coming back too because
he's no longer on legends of tomorrow the old man
with the glasses that you see in the background
here seems like their version of jonathan ken
just as he gets older but they introduced their
new twin sons formerly baby john kent that you saw
last before crisis on infinite earth started in
the other new sun his name is jordan kent so you
have a version of comic book john kent superboy
but you also have the second son now the the twin
boys the other one's jordan kent then he talks
about growing up and changing and being stressed
fiber stretching breaking bonds breaking and
they transition to what you might think of as the
crystalline fortress of solitude imagery with this
golden strand but the scene of superman trying to
use this golden rope to bring together all these
different crystal facets holding the members of
his family is actually a deep cut reference for
earth 2 superman from infinite crisis that was the
second big crisis event after a crisis on infinite
earths back in the 80s infinite crisis happened
in the early 2000s if you don't remember that
storyline it was found out that the og golden age
version of superman from earth 2 superboy prime
in alexander luther another alternate version
of lex luthor from another earth and a couple
other people like power girl had been trapped in
this sort of alternate bubble of continuity this
paradise dimension outside of the main reality
to protect them from the effects of crisis on
infinite earths because during that event in the
80s their worlds had been destroyed golden age
superman's lois is slowly dying and they feel like
bringing back their version of earth will heal her
so alexander luther who was a hero during crisis
on infinite earth kind of turns into the villain
and hatches a plan to bring back their earth
and replace the current dc version of earth
with theirs superboy prime went on from this event
to become one of the biggest villains in dc comics
they don't use him that much nowadays but every
once in a while he pops up he's like the biggest
in dc comics but during that event you also see
golden age superman literally punching his way
out of this crystalline dimension so it looks
just like this imagery here then superman goes
into this big speech about being stronger inside
despite the fact he might be broken i think while
he's doing this he's pulling together the fastest
of his family it's because they're trying to hype
up their twin superboy sons so much it's all
about a lead-in for potentially this younger son
getting a little twisted up some of this
imagery also makes him look a little bit crazy
and the older john kent kind of seems like he's
coming across as the more legit heir to the cape
and crest in early theory the younger son jordan
kent breaks bad a little bit because why would
you do twin super boys if one of them wasn't going
to break bad like you have super boy but then you
also have superboy prime they haven't completely
fully explained the scope of the show we just know
that they're going to be trading heavily on crisis
on infinite earth's tropes so what happened is is
that before crisis they had this baby that they'd
been hyping up like they'd had baby john kent
from the comics it seemed pretty straightforward
like okay eventually he'll grow up he'll become
superboy someday but because he was a baby right
before crisis and then right after crisis oliver
queen as the spectre reboots the multiverse even
though for some reason a lot of the characters
don't know that there's a multiverse anymore
i'll address that in a second too because that
was a big question mark as a result of the changes
in this new earth prime with them combining the
earth's from a couple different places so that all
the supergirl characters wind up on the same earth
as all the flash characters and the rest of the
arrowverse so that it all kind of makes sense that
they've all been interacting with each other this
whole time but while that was happening they also
used it to sort of tune things for the tv show
the people that are working on the actual superman
show wanted to write it a little bit older so
they just used that as an opportunity to age
up and add an extra sun so they're both supposed
to be in high school when this show is happening
so you have to remember when smallville started
how clark was basically a freshman in high school
you have to imagine them going through
a lot of the same paces albeit sped
up as the original smallville superman like
learning to use their powers for the first time
what do you do when you want to play football
but you're not allowed to use your powers
all the adventures in the comedy that comes with
that all beat with a much more sophisticated twist
on the multiverse the whole thing with henry
cavill superman in the movies though is that
right now it seems like he is negotiating to
cameo in a couple of upcoming movies i would
say the strongest possibility would be for him to
show up in the black adam movie because the rock
was literally hyping up fighting superman
in his trailer they released at dc fandom
you know i always thought that it might be
cool to hang out with superman that would be
cool right i mean we're kind of similar in terms
of our powers our strengths our speeds because
look at the end of the day you never know
black adam and superman could become friends
or they won't who knows maybe we'll see i don't
know what that is if that's not him hyping up
superman versus black adam but zachary levi has
been talking about getting him in the shazam
movie along with wonder woman they even put him in
that post-credit scene from the first shazam movie
and obviously we're going to be seeing black
suit superman a very different version of
superman that we saw in the theatrical cut of
justice league in the snyder cut in march all
the justice league snyder cut episodes are going
to start dropping at the end of march then if
you've been hearing rumors about jj abrams in
this new superman man of steel 2 movie it does
sound like he's actually reaching out to other
people to develop some sort of superman project
patty jenkins also said that she would love
to direct a superman movie but she's already
booked solid so i don't think there's any chance
that she would do the next superman movie she's
already doing wonder woman 3 she's already booked
for that star wars rogue squadron movie so whoever
does the next man of steel movie with henry cavill
is probably going to be somebody totally different
and just because there are rumors about jj
abrams reaching out to other writers about
writing the next superman movie that doesn't
mean that he'll wind up directing it himself
but you will remember a long time ago there was
his superman flyby movie i'm not a big fan of
that script it's online you can actually go out
and read it if you want to but there was a time
when he tried to get a version of a superman movie
made but if you're bummed out that there is no man
of steel two right now it does sound like they do
have plans to do another superman movie it's just
gong to take a couple years for them to get it
together dc is taking the new multiverse approach
with its movies as well so they're kind of doing
the tv show thing where everybody can exist all at
the same time it's just all happening in different
realities that's how you get to all the different
versions of batman like we have robert pattinson
in the batman movie with matt reeves we have the
michael keaton batman from his tim burton movies
coming back in the flash movie and we have the ben
affleck batman also coming to the flash flashpoint
movie it is going to be batman into the bat first
in the next couple of years it's a really good
time to be a batman fan and really good time
to be a superman fan there's a bunch of videos
that i'm working on right now i'll try to get
them out as fast as possible but everyone click
here for my wonder woman 1984 post credit scene
video in easter eggs and click here for my brand
new mandalorian season 3 luke skywalker video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!